watashi no Kananga no Omaha : that the
agreement my wife tells me that I'm a
very lucky man
total ah amigo MPO freedom oh no I gonna
die no Janani or the Science Guy taught
at Weymouth and I think I've been lucky
because I've been able to participate in
the last time the last era when we can
make films with paper pencil and film
Dakara ah no casino gajanan Connie
potestas no Cunha estamos en su Amos and
Easton sin so demo guitar es más de
Guerre dough demo senses not fun okay ah
mokra no intro tato tomochka Renato
demos another fact of luck is that my
country has not been at war for the 50
years that I have been making films of
course we've profited from Wars but
we're very fortunate that we have not
had to go to war ourselves
hey Dino coma cure esta moreor Tania
heightens for Eva's go voters von
däniken wari Massimo
let's go see des neige Antonio gap don't
worry Otto whatever stop but my greatest
look is that I've been able to meet miss
Maureen O'Hara today
so I've been so happy and feel so
blessed with luck in my life thank you